So, it sounds as though what you have is the system component is responsible for
causing the input to be read in, causing it to be parsed into pieces
getting storing those pieces into the line and
word data structures, and organizing index.
Okay? And then calling the circular ship to do his thing, and
then ultimately calling the sorted view to do its thing.
Now sometimes when you put a lot of responsibility for
organizing steps and behavior and algorithms inside of one piece,
you may want to break that piece into, into parts.
So, this particular solution is similar to
Parnas' approach which he called the Shared Data Decomposition.
Well, we're the system into components based upon the functions they compute.
And all components share access to the data, which is stored in, in, in memory.
So you have a component several data structure components which are then
accessible to the circular sorter and
to the the circular shifter and, and to the sorter.
And this solution solutions like this typically contain some form of
what's called a master controller routine, which you have labeled as systems.
And it's responsible for invoking the others and knowing what steps are,
are in the process and that the typically in a situation like this,
control flow dependencies, is, are organized or realized by function calls.